Look, it's been a wonderful day.
I told the guys I'm happy, I'm not sad.
So, it feels great to be here.
And I enjoyed tying my shoes one more time...
...and everything was the last time.
It is amazing.
It really is.
I didn't want it to feel lonely out there.
I felt lonely for a second when they told me to go out...
...or you wanted me to come out one more time.
And it felt great.
But to be saying goodbye in the team,...
...I always felt I was a team player at heart.
Singles doesn't really do that a whole lot,...
...but I've had a team that traveled with me around the world...
...and it's been amazing with them.
So, thanks to everybody who made it work for so many years.
So, it's been a perfect journey.
I would do it all over again.
It's been great.
It's been so much fun.
It's been amazing.
Thank you, everybody.
I've had so many people cheer me on and you guys here tonight means the world.